Cassidy congratulations on making it to
final three what an insane ending to an
amazing season I feel like you
accomplished so much not only for
yourself but for the women on this
season and just for women who have
played this game in general how are you
feeling now that the dust has settled
and everything has played out
yeah
um I appreciate you saying that because
that was a big theme I guess of my game
and
um it's tough I mean I almost
foreshadowed it for myself that like a
woman can't play the same game that a
man can and win and so it's tough to
like realize like
that I you know I knew that going in and
it still seems like that's kind of the
almost inevitable outcome for me but you
know I'm I'm feeling okay I I I think I
Gaslight myself a lot this these last
few months like trying to process like
was it in my head like was I create like
did I not really not have any shot like
did I not deserve it la la
um was I wrong to be surprised by the
outcome and I think after seeing you
know what every ever like everyone
watched it and seeing their thoughts I
think I feel like justified in how I
felt
um not to take away from the winner but
it was I mean I guess that it's like
some small consolation that people did
see my game and they and they feel like
I deserve to win so I do appreciate that
but
um It's Gonna Take I mean I don't know
if I'll ever fully get over it no
absolutely and that totally makes sense
I totally understand what you're saying
well to a degree obviously I've never
been on Survivor but from as a viewer
and as someone who loved you on this
season I was rooting for you every time
you won a challenge I was like yes
screaming at my TV I was so excited now
if you want to talk about what Carl said
to you about how you know if she made it
to jury she was going to be poisoning
the jury basically and do you think that
played a big part in how everything
played out at the end
yeah I mean
I I personally I do
yeah people will say I think people are
defending their decision on the jury and
so they're going to say no but the thing
was as soon as I got out of the game I
can't remember who but somebody from
Ponderosa told me
um that that's exactly what happened and
it was somebody who didn't hear a
conversation who wasn't even
um present on the beach at that time so
to hear that from somebody and then like
I obviously like I've spoken to Carla
about it and she denies it but at the
same time she also told me they had
already pretty much made the decision to
vote Gayla over me and so I I can't
imagine that things weren't said that
you know especially going into final
tribal like to her for her to say like
they had pretty much already decided him
as the winner
um like I don't know how much I trust
what she is telling me but
I don't know I it's it's yeah what can I
do a mixed bag of emotions I feel yeah I
feel processing and that's 100 okay
there are also some other moments during
the final tribal
um where there's one in particular that
I want to talk about where the ride or
die Alliance basically like discredited
what you had done when with your plan to
get out Ryan they said it was their plan
he asked them everything kind of went
down how are you feeling in that moment
like when they were all talking about
well no Cassie didn't make that move
kind of thing yeah it felt like from the
beginning of of that final tribal that
um that sorry I'm in a hotel room myself
um that no matter what I said or did it
was like they were already closed off to
me and they were very open to gabler and
like they were laughing they were like
Grant what he said like Brian was
jumping to his defense which like
literally not surprised at all that Ryan
was took that torch
um pun intended but like it just felt
like
it didn't really matter what I said you
know and I did my best to you know and
even after that like they didn't I don't
think they showed it but like I talked
about They didn't accept that move so I
was like okay let me give you another
example since obviously like my
perception on that was not what you guys
perceived it as and so I was like
um you know the afternoon that Noel
brought everyone on the reward I was
able to convince Cody to vote Noel out
that vote and he even agreed with me at
that tribal that that that was a big
thing that had swayed him and that was a
huge turning point in the game for me
um and so
I I was able to like take credit for
that move but they just didn't air it
yeah absolutely that's so lovely map
like at the end what I have said yeah I
love hearing that stuff and it's sad
that we didn't get to see it and I feel
like
yeah I don't know there's so many
emotions going on and I can only imagine
for you now I also want to talk about
Jesse when he expressed to you or to
everyone on the jury that he was like
hey it was my idea for Cass to possibly
you know make fire against me now I need
to know do you feel like that also hurt
your chances and were you ever
considering going out there and doing
the fire against him yeah so it I think
that had a huge sway I think that he
told everybody like that's what she
should have done to win and blah blah
and got that idea in people's heads and
so everybody was like well she didn't
since she didn't do that she doesn't
deserve it instead of looking
objectively at my whole game I think
it's really unfair to to even make that
stipulation because obviously that was
the best move for him because he thought
he could he had the best chance of
beating me but for him to take that back
and say that that's like what I needed
to deserve the win I think that's BS I
think I earned my spot I worked really
hard and that like that challenge was a
ton of pressure and I did what nobody
else could do with that final immunity I
earned that power and to ask me to give
it up like a Chris Underwood style like
I played the game I worked myself I
didn't I wasn't on you know I can't
remember what the island was they were
on but like I was in the game the whole
time I didn't need to come at the end
swoop in and and make that move I
understand why he did and good for him
but that shouldn't be like uh I don't
think that should be a decision like a
final decision maker and unless like you
just completely did nothing in the game
but that was not the case for me so I
just was like I didn't understand why
they were putting that that stipulation
on me when I don't think they would have
put that on anybody else
absolutely I totally agree with you
um and was there ever a moment
afterwards I mean I don't want to talk
too much about regrets because I feel
like there are so many good moments that
you had but did you ever regret picking
Jesse and gabler to do fire together
knowing you know gabler saying that he
was so good at making fire yeah I mean
there was there was times when I've
questioned it at the time I was like
this is ridiculous like I'm not I'm not
putting myself in Fire and then you know
because I didn't feel that confident in
my firemaking abilities and I just
didn't think that it was a fair like
thing to to require of me I feel like I
had played a good game up to that point
and the most well-rounded game obviously
like not of the I didn't play the best
game of the season but it doesn't matter
how good of a game you play if you can't
get to the end and the people that I was
sitting next to I felt like I had played
the best game so yeah obviously I've
gone back in my head over and over like
should I have done that and there were
moments where I was like yeah like I
definitely would have won if I had done
that but
at the same time if I had done that and
I failed how big of an idiot would I
look like you know what I mean like I
would have never lived that down and
people would have been like why would
she do that a lot so he does like I
didn't really it was damned if you do
damned if you don't yeah and so that was
that's kind of what I felt like going
into tribal for me in general
yeah absolutely I I totally I see where
you're coming from it like you said damn
you damned if you don't I mean you and
Owen were so shocked when the votes were
being read seven to one your boy James
gave you the vote that you you deserve
more but you got that vote
um and I know although you know you
didn't take home the grand prize you
still came out of Survivor like I said
with so many amazing things that you
accomplished
how would you describe your Survivor
journey in like three words overall
three words
oh man
I'm bad with words no I'm just kidding
um
I want to say life-changing
um
perspective shifting
and just exhilarating
those are three perfect words I feel
like to describe your whole journey and
as a Survivor fan it was amazing to
watch you just absolutely kill it at the
end no one thought you were gonna make
it that far everyone's trying to get you
out throughout the whole season so Props
to you and thank you so much for this
chat today and congratulations again on
everything you accomplished thank you so
much I appreciate that I'm proud of the
game I played and there really was I
don't think I curved anything else I
left it all out there and you know I'm
I'm I feel like a winner at heart so
might not be a million that's okay
there's ever another opportunity I feel
like maybe take it who knows I feel like
I would absolutely but then like the
thought of having to do that all over
again I mean I would
I just I hope I have it in me twice that
would be amazing